légende de pendu deux artistes
promouvoir le tourisme de trois rivières
[Musique]
est ce que toutes les villes et les
villages du québec ont leur folklore
associés à des histoires de fantômes des
histoires de hantise de pendus ou de
gens condamnés à mort souvent sous de
fausses accusations
c'est le cas de la ville de
trois-rivières qui fait la promotion sur
ses sites web de la légende d'un
autochtone appelé noël place aux as qui
aurait été pendus en 1790 sur le mur
n'en reste du couvent des récollets qui
est aujourd'hui le presbytère de
l'église saint james
à l'époque le couvain serait de prison
en afin que la prison de trois-rivières
soit construit
elle place à arette toujours clamé son
innocence et à sa mort il aurait proféré
une malédiction contre le mur sur lequel
il a été pendu quelques heures après sa
pendaison
le mur se serait en partie effondré
depuis on dit qu'à l'église saint james
on peut entendre des cris on veut
entendre noël placera proférées sa
malédiction
rien de mieux qu'une bonne histoire des
antilles ce qu'un vieux folklore pour
attiser la curiosité des historiens et
ces derniers ont commencé à fouiller
dans les archives et ont découvert un
article dans le québec mercury septembre
1825 on est donc beaucoup plus tard que
la date de la légende et dans deux cuves
et mercury on mentionne effectivement la
condamnation à mort d'un autochtone
appelé noël françois ce qui ressemble
beaucoup à noël la soa et cet homme est
accusé d'avoir assassiné un trappeur
dumont d'antoine bibeau qu en 1825 noël
françois n'aurait probablement pas été
pendus contre le mur du couvent des
récollets ou ce qui est aujourd'hui le
mur du presbytère de l'église saint
james
il aurait probablement été pendus à la
prison de trois-rivières qui était bel
et bien construite à cette époque alors
ce qu'on réalise ici c'est que parfois
on peut s'amuser avec la légende avec
les histoires on peut le trafic et même
les dates afin de promouvoir un tourisme
afin de s'assurer que les gens viennent
visiter les lieux les plus historiques
d'une ville ou d'un village
[Musique]